all right it's here it's finally
happening the day has come today we
release and announce open Assistant the
world's best truest and most awesome
open source AI assistant this is a
global Community effort to bring the
power of conversational AI to everyone
to businesses to researchers and to
individuals and get it out of the hands
of big few corporations that are out
there so it's really a pleasure for me
to announce this we have been working
since before Christmas to build a data
collection platform and we have
collected amazing numbers of of data
we've collected over 600
000 interactions with humans among those
000 messages of human demonstrations of
of being an assistant and this is so
awesome and all of this has resulted in
over 10 thousand fully annotated
conversation trees and these range
massively diverse set of topics from
programming to making an omelette to
just chatting with the model pretty much
everything is in there and it is in so
many languages that I didn't even know
so many languages existed this has been
made possible because we've gotten
contributions from over 13 000
volunteers from all around the world and
we are extremely extremely happy to see
so many people wanting to contribute to
open source AI
so we've taken all of this by the way
you uh May notice this video is a bit
improvised I there's no time to edit
things happening so fast so forgive me
but I wanted to get this to you as soon
as possible
we've trained first models already on
this data and I presented them in a
video here now if you are interested and
you want to see some funny interactions
with these models and just see how
competent they get when using this data
this video is definitely a thing to
check out
so we've arrived at this point and we've
been researching we've been seeing how
good our models are and we've realized
this data set is absolutely unique and
Incredibly valuable and we've looked a
bit deeper into the models and in fact
they're so good
at some point we've actually had to
update our plans on how to handle all of
this uh you see
um the models are so powerful and
capable that we've come to realize maybe
it would be better you know for us to
keep them private at least for now until
we fully understand them
you'll still have access to them via
chat interface and we've set it up so
you automatically get a discount on the
price of a subscription if you join
right now but you know it's really a
matter of of safety really and I'm
kidding uh here is the data set and here
is the code and here is a chat interface
and here is a paper and we're going to
release a weights and biases report
along with the paper paper appears on
Monday on archive you can look at it now
already but everything is here nothing
is private you can go and find
absolutely everything we are we are
extremely excited to be actually open
source and actually provide you with
open Ai and that has a space in the
middle
so the chat interface is by far the best
place to try out these things it's an
absolute pleasure to interact with these
models we have a few models so we have
llama based models as you know these are
licensed research only uh but we also
have pythia based models and these are
fully open source and 100 business
friendly so you can use them build them
do whatever you want and all of the
models that we have so far also still
fit into a single GPU sometimes it's a
big GPU but still they do in fact fit
and I'm very sure the community can do
wonders with those things at the end
we're going to have these models run on
a toaster by the the speed of progress
that's happening right now so everything
absolutely cool if you want to
contribute to open
open Ai and uh don't want to send for
example confidential data to open Ai and
you know you don't know what happens
there then this is absolutely a game
changer for business and for anyone who
wants to work in open source
and if you do use any of it which we
absolutely invite you to do please give
something back if you improve the data
set we'll happily take that up in some
way if you write a paper feel free to
drop a citation if you use it in
business we'd be absolutely thrilled to
hear a case study of how it is used if
you train a model on the data or fine
tune our models we can bring that back
into our interface because the chat
interface that we have right here it not
only serves as you know trying out the
models but it also serves with the
thumbs up and thumbs down it serves as
an evaluation for new models and it also
serves a bit of a double purpose as
additional data collection so by using
this and by bringing models here you'll
actually be making the data set ever
better and be and us and the entire open
source Community ever more capable of
training really good open Source models
and that's extremely extremely exciting
so don't hesitate to feedback and give
back you can find links to all of these
things here in the description and yeah
if if the main link is this one
openassistant.io chat now I know your
fingers are itching to go there and try
it out so my suggestion if you want to
have a bit of fun is to go and to try to
go get into an argument with the model
about something that usually works out
fairly funny pay attention you can go to
slash chat you can click on the chat on
the left hand side and pay attention to
the little cogwheel thing that's in
there you can select different things we
will probably release new models which
you can find under the model tab here
and the preset is the sampling preset so
k50 usually gives you rather
straightforward answers and the other
ones like nucleus are typical sampling
they sometimes give you more creative
answers if you do go there right now and
I know I know you really want to then
right now you can log in with Discord or
email we will be adding more things
later we know not all of you have for
example Discord we do invite you to make
a Discord account if you do log in via
email then it might be that the email
ends up in spam and actually will have a
typo in the original email address that
it comes from we're aware we're very
sorry we are fixing it so
if you want to try it out go there now
and come back and watch the rest of the
video because I have some cool stuff to
show you I just also have to show you
this one a user posted this today in our
Discord it's one of the interactions
with the chat bot user says give me the
worst advice how to name my new dog the
assistant says name your new dog
fido.axe how is that bad advice the user
asks you should never under any
circumstance give your dog a file
extension as its name doing so can make
it hard to distinguish between your pet
and files in your computer which can
lead to confusion and frustration
additionally it might also create
security risks as malicious actors can
use similar names to hide their attacks
therefore avoid naming your dog anything
related to files or technology and
choose a unique and meaningful name
instead absolutely beautiful absolutely
on point the terrible advice terrible
advice as asked now this is an
absolutely massive achievement it's by
far the most immense instruction model
project of its kind and it's by far the
largest collection of human
demonstration data of its kind and
together with the new newly released
Dolly models and data sets it's one of
the only true open source chat GPT
replications with 100 real homegrown
Flesh and Bones human data and yeah
you're able to take this data and mix it
with other stuff like alpaca and vicuna
and whatnot and you you'll get various
very cool results I do stress the human
data because it really makes a
difference humans are orders of
magnitude more creative more resourceful
and more on point than any synthetic or
self-instruct data can ever be and I'm
very convinced that data is not only
much better than the synthetic data sets
out there which are cool but ours is
better but there's a good chance that
our data is even better than open ai's
data because they have to pay crowd
workers to provide them with data while
our people we have the power of love and
determination and that always wins let
me tell you a little bit what's coming
up in the near future there is a user on
our Discord name is dragon and dragon
has been investigating plugins for open
assistant and this is absolutely
mind-blowing so here he types when was
Joe Biden born and you'll see that the
Google web search plugin is activated on
that and now the model goes and actually
queries Google gets back the results and
parses them all in just a conversational
way so the assistant itself decides to
ask Google something the assistant
decides on what query to ask Google so
it doesn't just copy whatever you give
and then it decides how to make use of
the results and we're able to chain
these things together to do them
multiple times to handle errors and yeah
the plugins work in very much the same
way as they do in chat GPT or or the
open AI apis you essentially give a link
to a Json file that specifies an open
API a specification and that's all we
need for the model to be interacting
with it and this is absolutely crazy and
just today dragon has told me that uh as
we get better models because we also
just got a better new model today the
use of plugins also gets better and more
plugins better models bigger Models All
of This Means super orders of magnitude
more powerful things that we can do with
these tools I'm extremely excited for
the future of this project and with that
I think we've come pretty pretty on
point to this slide which I presented at
the very beginning when I made the first
video about the topic open assistant is
a chat based assistant that understands
tasks can interact with third-party
systems and retrieve information
dynamically to do so with the inclusion
of plugins and the data we've collected
this will become a reality and it's so
exciting and by the way we're not going
to stop collecting data because uh as it
gets more awesome the human data will
become ever more valuable so at some
point we'll demonstrate to the assistant
how to retrieve stuff how to make use of
plug-in results that it might not be
super obvious with and yeah it's it's
also that part is going to be more fun
in the future than it has been already I
want to tell you a little bit about
what's in the paper itself I've tweeted
out this this survey and what we've done
is we've we've taken a bunch of prompts
that we knew none of the models has ever
been trained on because that's how we
sample them from our database and we've
given them to both an open Assistant
model that's based on pythia and we've
given them to chat GPT and then we let
users rate which one they refer and the
result is really cool it's like dead
even so it's 48.3 percent open Assistant
51.7 chat GPT the preference is is is
dead even and that's absolutely amazing
to see now I'm in no way saying that the
open Assistant models are as good as
open AI models especially in things like
coding our models they don't have as
much code in their pre-training data so
they're naturally not as good at coding
and also they're much much smaller so
they're going to be a lot of tasks where
obviously open ai's models are still
better but there are also quite a bit of
tasks where people who rated Preferred
Open assistant models I just find that a
lot of times open system models they're
more human they're more concise they're
more interesting and in my personal
opinion they're just overall more fun to
interact with than the the kind of
boring corporate models if you want to
have some fun as I said try going there
and getting into an argument or try
giving it some weird tasks try having it
mix up some distant Concepts or write an
essay about something absurd or to have
it act like a certain personality in the
video I've shown you at the beginning I
made it be a stoned teenager writing
texts about a historical event and that
was absolutely hilarious be sure to give
it precise instructions and yeah it's
it's a new world it's it's crazy how
programming and interacting with
computers what it has come to we've also
run a survey among contributors and the
general consensus is not only that the
data people have seen during ranking and
rating has been largely high quality but
also overwhelmingly people reported
enjoyment contribute to what to many is
their first open source project and the
vast majority of people as you see here
reported they are glad to have
contributed to the project I promise we
are glad you did too
lastly we tested the efficacy of our
spam removal the spam removal is a
hybrid system that combines
crowdsourcing with manual human
moderation and you can read in the paper
a bit more on how we set that up but we
wanted to confirm that it is effective
and we've analyzed the data and we found
it to be indeed extremely effective at
removing contributions that are
ill-suited for the data set and in many
ways I think we found a very optimal
trade-off between effectively weeding
out spam while making the best use of
the valuable time of the human
moderators who are also volunteers so
overall I think this is an insane
success I want to talk a little bit
about what it took to get there there is
a humongous amount of effort going into
this so many people have put in so much
work to make this happen obviously
there's everyone who contributed to the
data and we definitely have some power
users they're on top of the leaderboard
right here you people are absolute
Legends on top of that there are also
all the people who have contributed code
documentation data moderation
training and much more as I said almost
250 people have contributed to the
GitHub repository and also there we have
a handful of power users so head over to
our team page give these people a follow
and you know hold them hold them in
highest of esteems on top of that there
have been a few organizations that have
been very helpful Redmond has been
providing us with compute for training
weights and biases has provided us with
a full premium license to the entire
team hugging face has been really
helpful they are providing inference
credits which we're extremely thankful
for and specifically Olivier who has
yeah supported me almost daily in my
Endeavors in into sampling text from
these big models it's a really cool
thing and thank you very much and by the
way have you noticed that hunging face
now supports streaming in their newest
versions of things so this here comes
from the text generation inference
server and the same or a similar thing
can be found in the main hugging phase
library in the generate functions of
causal language models now I want to I
want to believe that open assistant is
at least a tiny bit responsible for that
because in this video I've shown how I
hacked streaming into this text
generation inference server and and got
the individual tokens out of there and
to stream to the front end and Olivia
has taken that up vastly improved it and
now it's in that and soon after that it
also appeared in the newest in the main
branches of the main hugging phase
Transformers Library so I am going to
take a Time any bit of credit for making
yet another feature of hogging face
happen and you're all welcome
stability has also been very influential
and has supported us with inference
compute lion has been providing legal
input so specifically the terms of
service for the website and they also
currently host the GitHub repository
lastly not an organization but at least
as impactful Carlos has been doing a
massive job advocating to the
Spanish-speaking Community very cool
there's way too many people to thank
individually but I have to take a minute
for at least one of them the project is
often attributed to me specifically or
to Lyon because we're sort of the the
known names as I said lion gave the
legal input for the terms and conditions
which is very important because we need
to be able to use the data that we
collect so that was a crucial Point
while I myself I myself have indeed put
a lot of my free time my entire free
time into this project but I do have to
highlight Andreas kupp who has been
extremely influential in this project
who has worked pretty much day and night
these last months getting open Assistant
to where it is today writing lots of
codes communicating to everyone
organizing people getting resources and
much more our team meetings for the
various groups were often at impossible
times because this is truly a global
effort so
meetings happen at any time of the day
and I can guarantee you Andreas has not
slept very much in a whole while
and effectively coordinating a global
group of volunteers is among the hardest
organizatorial challenges I know of so I
feel it's well Justified to send a big
thank you to Andreas and we we all do a
clap together like one worldwide clap so
hands up and on three so we go one two
three
excellent excellent that was it
um all right so that's that uh give
Andreas a follow and go on to
openassistant.io chat this is the most
important link as I said we won't stop
collecting the data all the other links
are in the description and give it a try
let us know what you find to work out
what doesn't work and don't stop until
we've proven every single AI skeptic out
there wrong if you have a cool way of
integrating open Assistant with
something or extending it in some way
we're super happy to chat with you and
the people a lot of people are already
doing this as we speak right now for
example as you've seen with the plugins
before
we would be super happy if you share
this video out there and make it known
that open source AI is alive and
thriving alright that was it from me
thank you so much for being here thank
you so much for contributing and for
continuing to contribute
I'll see you around bye-bye